These bones, sitting next to the skulls of other human ancestors...
...are among the remains of three individuals that may add a new chapter...
...to the book of humanity.
Archaeologist Armand Mijares found the bones in a cave in a small Philippine island...
...and says they are between 50 and 67,000 years old.
By studying the collection that include bones from the foot and the femur,...
...the bone that links the knee and the hip, and a selection of teeth,...
...Mijares slowly came to the conclusion these bones may not be just ancient human bones...
...but a new species.
The creature was small.
Its scientific name is Homo Luzonensis,...
...and while it is certainly indigenous to the region, Mijares says it didn't die in the cave.
Mijares also doesn't know what ultimately happened to the species...
...but says the arrival of the larger, more robust humans may have led to its extinction.
Kevin Enochs, VOA News.